MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So we're here at Devoxx 2013.
We're back.
And we have the Angular guys.
Igor and Misko, welcome back.
MISKO HIVERY: Thank you.
IGOR MINAR: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: You guys were
very popular last year.
I think you did even
better this year.
You were all over the place.
You had university
session, three hours,
which will be online.
And I heard good
things about it,
how you managed
those three hours.
You had a code lab which was
kind of full, lots of people.
IGOR MINAR: The code
lab was awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: And you're
just back from a what
you think the future of
Angular will be session.
So you liking the
conference so far?
IGOR MINAR: It's pretty good.
We've always liked Devoxx.
It's great to be here.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I think
you had kind of a hockey stick
thing going on last
year, around Devoxx.
I'm not sure this is really--
MISKO HIVERY: We're giving
Devoxx all the credit.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, OK.
Great.
So let's step back for a second.
Angular, for anybody
that's been living
under a rock for the
past couple years now,
I guess, what are
we talking about?
IGOR MINAR: We're
talking about framework
for building client-side
web applications
with HTML and JavaScript, CSS.
We focus on developer activity
and combining all these web
technologies into
something that's
really pleasurable to use and
is also scalable and testable,
so that you can build
big applications
or small applications
depending on what you need.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
It's buzzword compliant.
Awesome.
So we're talking MVC
type of framework,
we're talking data binding.
Do you want to say a
word quickly about that?
MISKO HIVERY: Sure.
Data binding, it's just a
way for getting the data
from the heap, memory objects,
into the DOM, and backwards.
MALE SPEAKER: And back.
MISKO HIVERY: And back.
So that it interacts
with the DOM
through the input
fields, et cetera,
we update the
memory in response.
MALE SPEAKER: Directive scopes,
other major important concepts?
MISKO HIVERY: I think
directives is unique
because it's something
that is unique to us.
Nobody else has this
particular thing.
And the idea is extending
the vocabulary of HTML.
MALE SPEAKER: Dependency
injection, one of you
mentioned that.
That's important.
IGOR MINAR: So
dependency injection
is just a way of
assembling all the objects
and wiring the
application together,
which is great because you
don't need to do it by hand
and also makes the testability
[INAUDIBLE] much better.
MALE SPEAKER: So in the year
that you've had that, I think,
tremendous success, what are
the interesting or surprising
things you've seen
people do with Angular?
Has it been taken and
used in unusual places?
Is it exactly what
you had expected?
IGOR MINAR: Yes.
All the time.
We keep on being surprised about
things people do with Angular.
MISKO HIVERY: Like
putting it in a car.
IGOR MINAR: Put it in a car.
Seeing all kinds
of visual things
like drawing diagrams
in a declarative way,
taking text and translating
that into diagram.
We've seen slides.
MISKO HIVERY: Games.
IGOR MINAR: We've seen
games, mobile applications.
MISKO HIVERY: Mobile
apps on iPhone.
MALE SPEAKER: So I hear
here at Devoxx, the actual,
the thing on the screen is
actually built with Angular?
MISKO HIVERY: Yes
IGOR MINAR: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So it's
really all over the place.
IGOR MINAR: When we
started with Angular,
we really meant it to be a
way for building enterprise
applications, but
people have taken it
in very different
directions and it's
surprising to see what
they can do with Angular.
MALE SPEAKER: What you
mentioned in one of the session
was that you felt really
well about the fact
that people are
actually building stuff
they weren't able to
build before, or not
with the same productivity.
So you can actually get
something done in a weekend,
whereas before it was this
whole scaffolding and dragging
libraries.
IGOR MINAR: Right.
I mentioned it before,
but it's really nice
when I talk to people
and they say, hey,
I was able to build this
app that otherwise wouldn't
exist if weren't for Angular.
And I feel really good
about it because I
feel like these applications
can really change the way people
interact and how they
do things, and how
technology can make life better.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's see.
There's been a
number of new things.
So first of all, Angular
1.2 was released.
MISKO HIVERY: Finally.
MALE SPEAKER: Finally.
Just in time for Devoxx.
Thank you very much.
IGOR MINAR: I'm not
sure if it's related.
It was pretty close, and
we were heading for Devoxx,
so we're like yeah, it's time.
Cut it.
MALE SPEAKER: It's Devoxx-driven
development, right?
DDD.
IGOR MINAR: DDD.
MALE SPEAKER: There we go.
So animations, who
wants to talk about?
MISKO HIVERY: Yes.
Animations are also,
I think, something
that we're very proud of.
It's a very unique
take on animations.
And I think most
frameworks just give you
a bunch of APIs to use.
And we kind of
stood back and said,
how could the
animations look like
if this was just
designed from scratch?
How can we do it
all declarative?
And so on.
And so we really focused on
just making CSS-based animations
just work out-of-the-box.
So if you want to
add animations,
it's as simple as just adding
a whole bunch of CSS animation
code.
MALE SPEAKER: Don't used
too much of it though.
I mean, animations, you
don't want to overdo it.
MISKO HIVERY: No, you
But you want to make
it easy for people.
So you want to have a
subtle animation that
helps in getting the
point across rather
then just animation
for animation sake.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
It's not just for being pretty.
There's a purpose.
There's UX concerns with it.
Do you want to talk about
improved error messages?
I think that's an important
one, a day to day improvement
that makes a difference.
IGOR MINAR: So this is one of
the things that bothered me
personally because when
I see people struggle
with their applications
when they don't know what
is happening, and they get
very unhelpful error messages,
it's not a good spot to be in.
Because not only the
application's not working,
but now you're getting some
information that is not
helpful in getting you
from this bad place.
So what we did with Angular is
we identified all of the places
where we throw error
exceptions from,
and we gave them
unique identifiers
and gave them very
descriptive error messages.
And also linked them
to a documentation page
where this message is described
in a much larger scope
and it describes the situations
where the error's happened.
But as we were adding
these error messages,
we were quickly
realizing that we
were adding bytes to AngularJS.
And that's never a good
thing for client-side code.
You want to keep
the payload small.
So one thing that we
came up with was hey,
let's just strip all
these error messages
from the minified
file, but make it
possible to reconstitute the
error messages on the server
just by clicking
on the link, if you
had the need to debug
something in production.
So it gives you the
possibility of debugging things
in production, have you
had the need, as well as
smaller payload.
But in development, you get full
error messages and everything
is the way it should be.
MALE SPEAKER: The
way you expect it.
So speaking of development,
what is the typical developer
environment for somebody
that's using Angular?
What do you see out there?
Or do you recommend anything?
MISKO HIVERY: I don't think
we recommend anything.
People use Sublime
from vi to Emacs,
the standard stuff, Eclipse.
MALE SPEAKER: Which
is probably one
of the nice things
about Angular--
MISKO HIVERY: WebStorm.
I personally use WebStorm.
MALE SPEAKER: --prescriptive
in that sense.
MISKO HIVERY: But there
is a couple of IDs
that are actually
building it in.
Netbeans sent something
from JBoss, was it?
IGOR MINAR: I don't
know about JBoss,
but WebStorm-- WebStorm has a
decent support for AngularJS.
Netbeans is working
hard on that and stuff.
But from the whole workflow,
what I'm happy about
is how Angular encourages
the test-turn development.
And developers actually
take this advice
and use test-turn
development technique
to build their applications.
Tools like Karma
really help with that.
And I'm just glad to
see that in practice.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's
talk about the future.
So one question I think
you guys get quite often
is well, standards
are showing up.
There are things
like Web Components.
How does that influence
the roadmap and what
you guys are doing with Angular?
Does it clash with what
you've done already?
MISKO HIVERY: No.
So we actually talked about it
in our future of Angular talk,
and how we would like
to be on top of it,
and how Web Components
is specifically--
MALE SPEAKER: The observed part.
IGOR MINAR: Shadow DOM.
MISKO HIVERY: Shadow DOM.
How specifically Shadow Dom is
helping us making that happen.
Object.observe is another
area, DOM mutation observers,
and so on.
MALE SPEAKER: So all
the dirty-checking that
you're doing today is something
that would go away with--
MISKO HIVERY: Yes,
with Object.observe.
And it's a standard
we helped to write.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
You influenced it.
Is that fair to say?
IGOR MINAR: Yes.
MISKO HIVERY: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: The other
thing you talked about
was how you like
for developers to be
able to use parts of
Angular without dragging
the whole thing, so maybe just
the dependency injection for--
IGOR MINAR: Right.
So I personally believe
that modularization
will be a key component
of the web development
or the whole web
ecosystem in the future.
And this is what we would
like to take to our hearts
and break Angular into smaller
pieces, each focused on one
particular task.
For example, you mentioned
dependency injection.
There's no reason why
dependency injection
needs to be built into Angular.
We can just extract it, create
a separate library out of it,
and then use it in Angular.
But you can also use
it without Angular
in [INAUDIBLE] application,
or some other application
or anywhere.
MALE SPEAKER: Good.
Any other things
you find important,
in terms of the feedback you've
gotten that you've taken,
and that you think
will influence
the future of Angular?
IGOR MINAR: So one of the things
that we would like to do more
is get more of the
community feedback
on things we are doing.
MALE SPEAKER: What's a
good channel for that?
IGOR MINAR: Definitely follow
on Twitter and Google+ feeds.
We're going to be sharing
some of the proposals
for the future versions
of Angular and things
that we want to do.
And we would like community to
help us by providing feedback
on these proposals and help
us with reviews and stuff
like that.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So we're at Devoxx.
One of the big announcements
here was Dart 1.0.
I here there's an
intersection with Angular.
Do you want to go over
what happened there?
MISKO HIVERY: Yeah.
So we would like you have
a choice in which language
you want to use.
In JavaScript, you have
CoffeeScript, et cetera.
And all of these
are semantically
equivalent to JavaScript, so
you can just use AngularJS out
of the box with them.
But Dart is semantically
a little different.
And so we actually made a port
of Angular on top of Dart.
And it's actually used
internally at Google.
So there's real
apps running on it,
as opposed to just hypothetical.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
In production at Google.
MISKO HIVERY: Yes.
IGOR MINAR: So at
Google, currently we
run both the Dart applications
and JavaScript applications.
Because one thing that
we see is that language
is such a sensitive
topic among developers.
There are people who have
different backgrounds, who
have different preferences.
And you can't just tell
them this is the only thing
that you can use.
And it really is up to the
project, up to the team,
to pick whatever they feel
comfortable and productive in
and use that technology.
And Angular now
gives them the option
to go either with
Dart or JavaScript.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So where should
people go to find out
what's available today,
1.2, and the future?
Obviously, the
website, angularjs.org?
IGOR MINAR: Yup, angularjs.org.
And on Twitter, it's @angularjs
and Google+, +angularjs.
MALE SPEAKER: You guys are
having a conference soon, I
hear.
An Angular conference?
IGOR MINAR: Yup.
We have a really
awesome community,
if we haven't mentioned it.
And some of the members
of the community
are throwing an
AngularJS conference
which we are taking part in.
And this will take place
in January, mid-January.
And we're really
looking forward.
MALE SPEAKER: Looking
forward to that one.
Thank you guys.
Wish you all the
best for the future.
And thanks for watching.
IGOR MINAR: Thank you.
MISKO HIVERY: Thank you.